good morning everybody happy Friday it
is time for gratitude sure in the live
stream I pretend super excited to be
back with you so quick recap why we do
this is important to be good morning it
leads to your happiness as an
entrepreneur we need we know that we
have to stay positive optimistic achieve
our goals it doesn't mean that we're
complacent though doesn't mean that we
just accept things we still drive
forward but you can also be at the same
time grateful for the things that you do
already have in your life so we do this
every day Monday to Friday I do this
with my team and I brought it to you
guys to two most important parts one its
daily it's everyday it's a daily
practice is a dealing exercise you can
do 20 steel if you want but it's not a
once a week thing you got to commit to
it into that you really actually feel it
hard guys hard you got to actually take
a couple seconds to really feel it and
not just list something off because you
don't get the benefits or just listen it
off it's gonna touch you here and not
just here super important so today for
those of you for watching on the replay
afterwards leave it in the comments
below three things that you break before
you do that consistently for a week
you're gonna feel a lot better about
yourself above your life and the mission
that you're on so I'm gonna go first and
then see what you guys have to say I'm
I'm grateful for my co-host Rishi County
vnj rise on my new League of Legends
stream that we're starting right after
this
in 9 minutes and when you're doing
something new it can be hard to go out
and do it on your own
and I'm still happy to go and do it on
my own you know I will be an army of one
just go and chase it but it's always
great to have amazing people along
they're right with you it makes it a lot
easier you get a lot more creative
energy and I
super I've been super happy with the
stream so far and wheeshing gr eyes have
been a big part of that being a part of
pretty much ever I think every game
everything that we put on
we're in episode 18 or 19 there's no 22
like crazy like that so yes thank you
guys I really appreciate that the number
two thing I was gonna say I was gonna
sleep bananas because I see this banana
here and and I'm excited to eat this
banana and so it's good to be people for
the little things as well not just you
know big things you might think about
family friends that kind of stuff but
I'm gonna add in I'm gonna do the banana
and I'm gonna do the pumpkin spice latte
that Jerry's brought me this morning
that's it that's a shadow to reaching up
and she's listed PSL in the chat a
couple times and I was always XP SL and
so I get to taste the pumpkin spice
latte and see how it is so grateful for
some good food this morning to tickle my
tastebuds
and number three I'm grateful for sunny
days because today in Toronto is really
cloudy you guys can't tell from from I
guess the sunshine yeah it's really
cloudy today and and sometimes you can
be like sometimes you have to go through
the cloudy days to appreciate the
sunshine right for a lot of areas in
your life your business and so when I
see a really cloudy day it's easy to get
it's easy to get down and gloomy and
Fiddle you know low but it reminds me of
the sunny day isn't art to come and so
on grief over when that sunny day comes
and I hope hopefully I will appreciate
it more when it actually does come so
let's get to you guys we've got six
minutes I finished a little I finished a
minute earlier than usual what are you
guys before let's get some shout outs
Sternoff cuisine oh say knows who the
body part of the day is number
before the people in my autism courts
are being supportive and helping me
understand it better I love it
number two my heart there it is body
part of the day comes a know my heart
for pumping blood to my body you don't
think about it often to ever but it's
quite important I agree man I don't
think about my heart that often but
thank you for putting it on my radar
this morning and number three is my mom
our relationship is a bit rocky at the
moment but I appreciate all the love
she's given me in the past I love that
one too because it's great to be able to
appreciate and be grateful for the
positive things about people even if you
know there's a lot of negatives to them
too
they might be like negatives now there
were negative in the past that doesn't
mean you still can't appreciate the
positives about them and I support it'll
help with the relationship team GRI is
is thankful for meditation which centers
Alliance insists the tone for my day so
it sounds like a morning meditation for
energy which flows to me and through me
to others and for computers which allow
us to create plenty and neck and share I
love it
Jane was also grateful for his dad
although we're not super close I can
depend on him first combination of
popular love and reason I love it new
future builder welcome aboard
I'm good I'm grateful to be able to take
moments to enjoy the beauty of nature in
our world I love it mushy compass just
give it all caps yes I love it people to
be here awesome
what's up Adrian you guys have audio
issues you getting audio issues I don't
know
now that we're like six minutes in or
any sound is strange all right Anthony
Rishi or superstar I agree sherry is
grateful for my wonderful neighbors with
the first smooth and safe sail home and
especially for my grandchildren which
brings me so much joy in my life happy
first birthday today Gavin
happy birthday Gavin he'll be up first
amazing birthday I know you thought I'm
gonna see this but we're sending the
gratitude through the atmosphere to you
sounds like static what's wrong with the
sound everybody having sound issues was
my ender youtuber Google but good
morning everybody else we got good
afternoon from London from Tochi Danny
is that broke hey Kevin hey Zach little
Leanne you sound
Kackley if that's a word all right
yeah much yay Jen Rishi we're where the
sand at you hopefully will fix next
stream yeah I did seven my strange
yesterday with no issue and I haven't
changed anything so hopefully it's a
temporary thing we're gonna hop on to
the business Q&A session after this on
the twitch channel at nine ten so
hopefully it's uh it's fixed by them
much Rico for both you two people for
you thankful for you both to I know what
you're talking about put people in the
stream probably I love it
oh forge a rising Rishi got it Anthony
hello from London how are you all what
else we got Adam before my little girl
do this November I love it Adam
congratulations that's exciting
Peter I'm people to be alive and I get
to enjoy another amazing day grateful
for all growth we've made this year I
love it being coached by my favorite
mentor and friend much fun people for my
beautiful daughter was born 15 years ago
today we got birthdays in the house I
love it that's awesome Jen Joe yeah
sound like static but manageable alright
you know what I'm grateful for quality
sound
do we have it it was a quality sound we
have it I'm gonna for you guys all
sticking through this with our sound
issues what else Kathleen I'm grateful
for young children who get who helped me
to get over painful
issues when I'm down they lift my
spirits and yes on this year's Greta and
people for the mentors I have in my life
I love it Alexandria be able to go back
to school and be able to find time to
write my novel I love it good luck on
the novel is that competing for my
family for my Seahawk player is doing
great I love it this for the Blue Jays
hopefully making the playoffs come on go
Jays go
Darren I'm people that this notification
I'm grateful that this notification to
watch this video by Evan which teachers
need to realize it being grateful
they're gonna step back for a hectic
lives just to be people thanks Evan
Thank You Erin for joining in clicking
that notification refer my everything
life I love it what else we have
yes sound problems j5o but I'm like
across the country so it's not a big
deal
thanks litrenta George I'm good with my
two great sons my life and accomplishing
50% of my weight loss goals I love that
girl is back and her favorite pair of
jeans that's right let's not render
high-five up to you for getting back in
your favorite pair of jeans guys it's at
9:10 I made not the twitch to answer
business questions and place in League
of Legends Jay riser a cheek up TV have
an amazing day feel that gratitude
hopefully the sound she's are better on
Monday close out the week strong you
seem to believe or whatever your one
word is I was easy